this year alone we have provided 2.3  billion pounds of Military Support  and we will do the same again next year  as you succeed in pushing back Russian  forces on the ground your homes your  hospitals your power stations are being  destroyed by the air  so to help you defend yourselves we are  today providing new air defense support  including 120 anti-aircraft guns radar  and anti-drone equipment  we're extending our training for the  Ukrainian Armed Forces to include  specialist expertise from UK Medics and  engineers  and we are stepping up our support to  help you through the cold hard winter  ahead  this includes winter kit for your troops  help for your amazing First Responders  and another 16 million pounds of  humanitarian assistance for food and  shelter yep  all right  we all keep working I'll teach you on  the phone next week or two anyway and  we'll we're going to follow up on all of  the  great pleasure  thank you  next week yeah that'll be great all  right